a banker in london
sends the latest stock info to his
colleagues in hong kong in less than a
second
with a single click a customer in new
york orders electronics made in beijing
transported across the ocean within days
by cargo plane or container ship
the speed and volume at which goods and
information move across the world today
is unprecedented in history but global
exchange itself is older than we
think reaching back over two thousand
years along a five thousand mile stretch
known as the silk road the silk road
wasn't actually a single road
but a network of multiple routes that
gradually emerged over centuries
connecting to various settlements and to
each other thread by thread
the first agricultural civilizations
were isolated places in fertile river
valleys
their travel impeded by surrounding
geography and fear of the unknown
but as they grew they found that the
arid deserts and steps on their borders
were inhabited not by the demons of
folklore
but nomadic tribes on horseback the
scythians who ranged from hungary to
mongolia had come in contact with the
civilizations of greece
egypt india and china these encounters
were often less than peaceful
but even through raids and warfare as
well as trade and protection of
traveling merchants in exchange for
tariffs
the nomads began to spread goods ideas
and technologies between
cultures with no direct contact one of
the most important strands of this
growing web was the persian royal road
completed by darius the first in the 5th
century bce
stretching nearly 2 000 miles from the
tigris river to the aegean sea
its regular relay points allowed goods
and messages to travel in nearly
one-tenth the time it would take a
single traveler
with alexander the great's conquest of
persia and expansion into central asia
through capturing cities like samarkand
and establishing new ones like
alexandria as shot the network of greek
egyptian persian and indian culture and
trade extended farther east than ever
before
laying the foundations for a bridge
between china and the west
this was realized in the second century
bce when an ambassador named shang qian
sent to negotiate with nomads in the
west returned to the han emperor with
tales of sophisticated civilizations
prosperous trade and exotic goods beyond
the western borders
ambassadors and merchants were sent
towards persia and india to trade silk
and jade for horses and cotton
along with armies to secure their
passage
eastern and western routes gradually
linked together into an integrated
system
spanning eurasia enabling cultural and
commercial exchange farther than ever
before
chinese goods made their way to rome
causing an outflow of gold that led to a
ban
on silk while roman glassware was highly
prized in china
military expeditions in central asia
also saw encounters between chinese and
roman soldiers
possibly even transmitting crossbow
technology to the western world
demand for exotic and foreign goods and
the profits they brought
kept the strands of the silk road intact
even as the roman empire disintegrated
and chinese dynasties rose and fell even
mongolian hordes
known for pillage and plunder actively
protected the trade routes rather than
disrupting them
but along with commodities these routes
also enabled the movement of traditions
innovations ideologies and languages
originating in india buddhism migrated
to china and japan to become the
dominant religion
there islam spread from the arabian
peninsula
into south asia blending with native
beliefs and leading to new faiths like
sikhism
and gunpowder made its way from china to
the middle east forging the futures of
the ottoman
safavid and mughal empires in a way the
silk road success
led to its own demise as new maritime
technologies like the magnetic compass
found their way to europe making long
land routes obsolete
meanwhile the collapse of mongol rule
was followed by china's withdrawal from
international trade
but even though the old routes and
networks did not last they had changed
the world forever and there was no going
back
europeans seeking new maritime routes to
the riches they knew
awaited in east asia led to the age of
exploration and expansion into africa
and the americas
today global interconnectedness shapes
our lives like never before
canadian shoppers buy t-shirts made in
bangladesh
japanese audiences watch british
television shows and tunisians use
american software to launch a revolution
the impact of globalization on culture
and economy is indisputable
but whatever its benefits and drawbacks
it is far from a new phenomenon
and though the mountains deserts and
oceans that once separated us
are now circumvented through supersonic
vehicles cross-continental communication
cables
and signals beamed through space rather
than caravans traveling for months
none of it would have been possible
without the pioneering cultures whose
efforts created the silk road
history's first world wide web
you